I
it's a big deal when a TV show reaches
100 episodes the Big Bang Theory has
doubled at their 200th episode will air
this Thursday on CBS n the cast got
together to celebrate in Kelly cuoco
well she was turning heads
you can groom I dress I look down I was
like that's a lot of color okay we're
good turning heads and getting our
sensors nervous Kaylee's bought in this
low-cut shear but not too sheer Marchesa
gown is next level compared to all the
post yoga shots the paparazzi seem
hungry for it's the same picture every
day I don't really don't understand the
excitement this is from her Instagram we
talked about it hurts that looks like
love to my pants if you're gonna spend
every day yoga you might as well look at
me my world wore pants you want to be
wearing talked about my favorite pair my
bachelor pad over my favorite almost
five months and she announced her split
from husband Ryan Sweeting Kate Lee's
been showing off her revenge body on red
carpets from the SAG Awards to the
Grammys is yoga the secret yoga is the
secret yoga is the reason I have been
yeah it's done everything mentally and
physically I love it Hayley cocoa Katie
and the Big Bang gang we're celebrating
their 200th episode with a slew of guest
stars including Stan Lee an original
Batman Adam West
we should have memorial services before
we die kind of thing you know how
wonderful that we get to have this
celebration like this while we're still
going and not dead at this bash the cast
is still reeling from a big bombshell
pack amigos up I got to work with a baby
next year that I don't know him my
parents are so excited because they're
getting to be TV grandparents I'm gonna
get them like t-shirts bearing like best
TV grandparents but don't expect baby
fever to grab Jim Parsons Sheldon even
though we finally had sex what's next
it's gonna put a baby I feel like
they'll do it again but where they have
a wedding I'm not a problem
no let's hope so we want to be here for
many more years of this because if the
support you guys given our show so thank
you so much
Kaylee's wardrobe while shooting a
little bit more dress down from a green
halter dress to jeans and a jacket but
which does she prefer when do you feel
the sexiest in yoga pants was at home
with the dogs drinking my wine after
yoga as we go to yoga to drink wine so
then I'm glad you earned it yeah I
earned it I swear the calories right
that good